I told you me now with reaction to
tonight's breaking news that the DOJ
Inspector General will finally
investigate potential FISA abuses by the
DOJ in the FBI he is the chairman of the
House in telling the forefront while his
colleagues have been lazy
Devin Nunez is with us congressman I'm
reaching a point of frustration here
we're talking about with these new
struck paid memos this was within the
3,000 plus page dump that we finally got
at the last minute that you had to
subpoena there's 1.2 million documents
congressman and I I applaud chairman
Goodlatte
but as we just heard from from
congressman Chaffetz he asked for these
documents in 2016
why how was it possible that rod
Rosenstein feels that he has the right
to withhold us not only from the
American people but Congress people like
you and Bob Goodlatte the chairman of
the Judiciary Committee your job is
oversight we do have checks and balances
the last time I checked the Constitution
sir mm-hmm so the more they dig the
worse it gets for them Sean so we have
to keep working we have to keep breaking
through this but as I've said eventually
we're going to get all of these
documents so let me just walk back a
little bit of the history that we have
with mr. struck and miss page in October
I asked what had happened didn't get any
information what had happened you know
between struck and page didn't know a
task free we asked is there anything
there that we need to see well finally
we see a leak to the Washington Post of
text messages at that point finally in
December
I asked DOJ to send me everything that
was pertinent and relevant to our
investigation and as you know at that
time we had informed Department of
Justice that we were looking at them for
FISA abuse and other matters so they
produce some of the text messages which
is fine they did that they said that was
all we needed well then a couple months
later a few more text messages show up a
couple weeks ago there's the
conversation between
mr. struck and miss page talking about
the FISA Court judge clearly that would
have been something that the House
Intelligence Committee would have been
interested in
and now the emails that are in text
messages that you're talking about today
on the show Sean I have not seen them
however we're now that it's you know you
have them we're gonna have to go you
know try to look through all this to try
to piece together what it appears what
are your initial impression do you agree
with what Sarah believes and I believe
well I was talking to a few members of
Congress today and these are people who
you know don't follow this closely
they're not on the House Intelligence
Committee but they follow it just by the
news and they were shocked they were
shocked matter of fact they used a few
expletives because they couldn't believe
that the White House the Obama White
House was being briefed by the FBI on an
investigation into the Trump campaign
they couldn't believe it and I think
that's the that's the reaction you're
gonna get from most members of Congress
that that care about this issues at
least the Republicans and I think you're
gonna see the American people this when
you have indeed what it continues to
stink and and then you have remember the
obviously Obama knew obviously Susan
Rice knew obviously James Comey was
informing them obviously and this is a
very sticky point because in January
2017 then president-elect Trump was told
by James Comey the dossier is salacious
and unverified but three months earlier
he's he's using it and the FBI is using
it as the bulk of an application for a
FISA warrant against the campaign
associate of Donald Trump in the lead up
to a presidential election which allows
them to then spy on the emails of an
opposition party candidate this is not a
game this is now to me the biggest abuse
of power
scandal we've had in history you get
these ridiculous people on the Left
making insane Watergate analogies but
Watergate was a cheap break in a
third-rate break-in this is about the
powerful tools of intelligence this is
about the FBI DOJ exonerating a
presidential candidate from crimes we
know that were committed
then using Russian information that they
didn't verify not telling a FISA Court
the whole truth it's like what do we
need to get the wheels of justice really
turning here because I know I'm fed up
and my audience is fed up yeah so
there's a lot of irony in that right so
so the left has continued to say that
this is Watergate and you know Trump's
gonna be in Peach they've continued that
well now this is effectively boomeranged
on them and you know you have at least I
think half of the American people now
know that the other party the Democrats
appear like they weaponize to some
degree the intelligence services you
know by using the foreign intelligence
surveillance apparatus in this country
to go and target the opposition campaign
is totally unacceptable
and that's what happened here and so
people are beginning to learn the truth
so I am happy that Bob Goodlatte
subpoenaed these 1.2 million documents
but I said this earlier in the week we
need those documents like yesterday
yesterday we needed those documents and
and what I think now the difference
where we were from a few months ago
because of the obstruction because of
the cover-up the pressure that the
American people are now putting on
Congress by making everybody aware of
this asking their congressmen why is it
the Department of Justice can Stonewall
Congress for this long
I believe that Bob Goodlatte subpoena is
going to be in force I think we're going
to get all the documents and if we don't
then we should move quickly to contempt
and then we should move to impeachment
one of the mistakes we made is we never
impeached Lois Lerner and we never
impeached
Costigan how do we had got away with it
we wouldn't be here today they got away
faith in the inspector general because
now he's gonna be investigating the FISA
abuses as he announced today I'm
frustrated because we've been all over
this story since your memo came out but
if I was James Comey Andrew McCabe Sally
Yates tonight rod Rosenstein struck and
Paige and Rebecca I would be very
worried tonight based on the possibility
that all this is coming out and if we
had an honest Inspector General then I
am thinking that some of them might be
in legal jeopardy in a
well yeah so let me tell you about the
Inspector General here's what I believe
okay they have a job to do so this is
this is part of the job that they should
be doing I believe that mr. Horowitz
from everything that I hear that he's an
honorable man and he's going to do his
job but remember there's a lot of
pressures that come with that because
the Inspector General ultimately his
boss is the Department of Justice so
this is not a simple move for the
Inspector General to make to go after
the top people in the FBI this is why I
think I'm glad that mr. Horowitz is
going to continue to look into this but
I also have a lot of concerns about that
there's no one else looking into this
because you weren't how are you gonna
get how are you gonna have mr. Comey
testified to the inspector general he's
not going to sit for an interview with
the inspector general and neither is mr.
McIlwaine either national counsel it was
Greg Jarrett was saying you made a
conclusion after 14 months you have no
evidence of the Trump campaign and
collusion nor any evidence of any
financial impropriety with the Trump
Organization and the campaign but yet
even after 14 months of a media
recklessly and hysterically reporting
and your so-called counterpart and MSNBC
wannabe contributor Adam Schiff who
actually shows up on Russian TV which is
a little ironic after all of that they
still how long is it do they want this
investigation in perpetuity is that what
they're looking for slow country gap in
the agenda the president what I find
amazing is is that we have a 250 page
report we have 70 findings and
recommendations the Democrats had none
okay that City now we finally sent that
over so it can be declassified so the
American people can read all of the
great work that our committee has done
over the last 14 months yet finally one
meet mainstream media outlet just find
me one that has actually done any
coverage whatsoever of any significance
on the 70 findings and they're busy with
me not with last week you won't find it
they're too busy trying to back like
Jerry Springer last question
you've watched some our coverage am i if
anything I've reported that's been wrong
or Sarah or John or Gregg Jarrett or Jay
Sekulow
or tom Fitton or any of the people
sebastian Gorka no look Shawn I think
you guys have been ahead of the curve on
this a lot of times there is information
that that some of the reporters you
mentioned they have it well before the
Congress has it that's all I know and
it's very tough it's very very tough
work that they're having to get through
because you have so many people if you
come out with a story even though it's
you're just like this story tonight
about these text messages that you guys
have uncovered you're not gonna see this
covered in the mainstream media you're
not gonna see it I guarantee you won't
happen over the next week all right we
need the 1.2 million documents and we
need a special counsel congressman Nunez
thank you for trying to be transparent
and honest to the American people we
appreciate it more than you know